[Musique]
sa partie au mieux représente mal un
site d'hivernage à plus de cent mille
oiseaux durant l'hiver et d'autres
critères qui sont des critères
pour la zone comzone à deux buts
diversité ou com'zones la quatrième zone
humide la plus importante en afrique du
nord
[Musique]
c'est
avec l'accélération des phénomènes liés
aux changements climatiques comme les
inondations la sécheresse et les
tempêtes
nous allons avoir de plus en plus de
problèmes dans la région méditerranéenne
et en tunisie en préservant ses espaces
là nous allons vraiment minimisé dans le
futur la la sévérité de ces phénomènes
et nous allons protéger notre zone
humide mais également toute la
population qui vit autour
bon
[Rires]